[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and welcome to our
continuing series on the concept of how
to eat how do you means belly power and
generally at the blanket term for the
ideas of making good alignments and
using your body in a good way the
simplest idea of how to eat is simply to
keep my hands in front of my Center so
if I need to do something over here
instead of moving my hands over there I
would move my belly over here to make a
good alignment to that however there are
things that look like hot eggy that are
psychological deceptions I'm going to
show you a classic psychological
deception from Aikido and talk about how
it's not hot Aggie but sometimes can
give the impression of that and why that
can be fun but sometimes dangerous to
play with you should be careful so along
with the concept of hot eb which is
actually how i align and use my body
sometimes we can have demonstrations
that look like a ton of ghee which would
be very impressive how to eat but in
fact isn't it's kind of a psychological
manipulation so one class of active
demonstration of this is if Sascha had
the the end of the stick here and Josh I
do both to grab the state if Sascha were
to convince us to push the stick down
flat right so meaning we can't drive it
down and weird angles or anything that
our job is simply to push the stick flat
to the ground so Sasha convinces us and
conditions us to drive the stick flat
like that now if we were to do that and
Sasha would not to let us go on that
side but you can see that this option is
easily able to keep us from pushing it
down now that seems impressive that
seems like some really impressive
honey-b back to what's happening is a
really simple psychological factor so
when Josh and I believe that the stick
has to go flat meaning has to go totally
flat to the ground if one end is kept up
so Sasha just won't let that man go down
well it happened inside my brain when
I'm really convinced is instead of just
at an angle which might make this easy
for me I will try to keep it flat right
so I'm actually helping something I'm
holding up on this side nowadays if
multiple people are involved in this
then what happens is I would suddenly
realize that I'm not pushing down all
the way another person will often
realize that's the case so as this
starts to get out of alignment then Josh
will change and now all of a sudden it
feels difficult to push down but I'm
really trying to push down and it won't
work so what's happening is a
psychological situation there where I'm
convinced that we have to obey some
special set of rules so it's not
actually cutting but it looks like
cutting
and that's another demonstration that
can be give to kind of explain how this
stuff works so it's important to
understand there's lots of ways that we
can give these kinds of demonstrations
in and a lot of people said that while
you as she would do it as a
demonstration was never what he would
teach in class sometimes to make a good
demonstration it's fun to show these
kinds of interesting ideas and they
really do show important key concepts
however they're not the essence of
Aikido there's a system that's
underlying all those things that's much
more important to Aikido overall however
these concepts are really fun they're
they're useful they help your students
kind of understand how the body works
and how leverage works so I highly
recommend practicing them but understand
the limitations of these exercises I'm
Chris Ryan thanks for watching our
series on huggy